الواسع فجرته تيك توكر اردنيه بعد قرار
خلع الحجاب عقب خمسه اشهر على ارتدائك
طبعا كما هو متوقع مشاهدينا وسائل الاعلام
الاجتماعي في الاردن ضجه باعلان التيك توك
ارسالي العوضي وسط اتهامات بانها تقصدت ان
تصبح ترند بما فعلته سالي ادعت بانها
تعرضت لحمله سب وشتم من قبل عدد كبير من
المتابعين وذكرت بان الكثيرين منهم تمنوا
لها الموت بسبب اتخاذها لهذا القرار
المثير للجدل
في المقاتله البالغه من العمر 18 عاما في
فيديو دون حجاب قائله انها لن تسامح كل من
ينتقدها او يتنمر عليها واكدت انها غير
قادره على الالتزام بارتداء الحجاب لفتره
اطول
ان اشلح
وا
[موسيقى]
نفكر وارجع بحكي
حرام حرام وبعد عيط اني فكرتها كل مره
بفكر هيك وبقعد اعيط تخيلوا التعليقات
مسكره
وانا
شلحت الحجاب معكم العوضي
وهاي انا ما في مشاكل الا انه سالي العوض
بشلحت حجابها ما في مشاكل يعني لما اسالك
تمشي في الشارع راح تكون هي السبب الفساد
الوحيد انتم كلكم ملائكه
[موسيقى]
كلكم سالنا الناس في الاردن لماذا يسر
البعض على ابداء الراي في قرارات القرارات
الشخصيه للاخرين عبر مواقع التواصل ماذا
اجابه
بمواقع التواصل الاجتماعي وغير مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي احنا ثقافتنا كشعب عربي
التدخل يعني كان بحياتك الشخصيه كان مع
اسرتك كان بالمجتمع بالبيئه المحيط اللي
انت عايش فيه اذا بتحس كل الناس بتحاول
تعرف شو انت بدك تعمل اليوم يعني في
تدخلات بتكون
من باب النصيحه من باب النقد من باب
انه الواحد مثلا يكون على غلط ممكن يتدخل
يحكي له كلمه بس في تدخلات هو والتطفل هي
النوع من انواع التطفل كل واحد وحياته انت
حياتك لحالك وانا حياتي وحياتي وكل واحد
الى حياته الى شخصيته والى
تصرفاته ماكو داعي واحد كل واحد يتدخل
بشخصيه الثاني
[موسيقى]
الموضوع ما بتعلق بمواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي الفضول المؤذي والتدخل بشؤون
الاخرين شغله موجوده طول عمرها بجمالها بس
معي وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي زادت
وبالتالي
فصار صارت الناس تشوف اكثر من الحياه
الشخصيه لغيرها سواء الناس بتعرفها او
الناس ما بتعرفها وبالتالي الفضاء
الافتراضي هذا اعطاهم مساحه انه
يتدخلوا بحياه الناس الثانيه ويدخله
بقراراتهم ويقولوا لهم هذا صح وهذا غلط
هلا الاشخاص طالما دخلت مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي وعملت اكاونت على السوشيال
ميديا فهي حطت اخبارها بشكل عام تفاصيل
حياتها على المواقع التواصل الاجتماعي هذا
الشيء بخلي الاخرين بشكل لا ارادي قاعد
بالبيت قاعد بالشغل قاعد مع الاصدقاء اني
اتدخل باي منشور نزل على المواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي سواء صار تريند او حتى ما صار
ترند
يلا نرحب مشاهدينا بصانعه المحتوى
للعوضي هي ضيفتنا في الاستوديو اليوم
تفضلي يا سالي معنا
تفضلي صباح الخير اهلا وسهلا فيك صباح
العربيه
طيب يا سالي بدنا نعرف القصه بالضبط انت
تحجبتي بعدين قرار شخصي وبعدين قررتي انك
تشلحي الحجاب شو صار على السوشيال ميديا
وشو اكثر يعني انت معنا اليوم لانه حسيتي
انه في تنمر كبير عليك اشرحي لنا شو اللي
حسسك بهذا الشيء
ايش اللي حسسني بالتنمر الاشي اللي بصير
علي
هلا كلهم عم بينتقدوني بطريقه يعني مش
انها فيها نصح لا بطريقه كتير سيئه
بغلطوا فيه بحكوا كتير سيء فهذا الشيء
اللي بحسسني انه انا عم بتعرض لهجومي كتير
كبير بحس انه دائما في اسلوب افضل للنصيحه
يعني مثلا تدعي لي تنصحني بطريقه افضل هيك
بحس افضل طيب خليني ارجع معك شوي شوي الى
قرار اتخاذ انه انت بدك ترتدي الحجاب جاء
عن قناعه ولا انه جاء انه مع صديقاتك ولا
كيف هلا انا زيي زي اي بنت تحجبت تماما
بالضبط انا لما لبست كنت كثير مقتنعه وانا
نفسيته كتير كنت مقتنعه وانا يعني ما طلبت
من حدا يطلعني ترند ولا اعلنت عن هذا
الشيء انا لما تحجبت تحجبت لربنا عشان حدا
ولا عشان حدا يطلعني ترند
الحمد لله تحجبت والامور تمام بعدين صرت
احس انه الناس كتير يعني انه عم بتقيدني
انه ما تغني انا ما بقدر اتخلى عن الغناء
انا بغني يعني انه ما تغني وانت وانت
متحجبه ايدك مبينه مثلا
رقبتك مبينه اشي حسيت حالي كتير متقيده
يعني هاي مش سالي انا حدا ابسط من هيك
يعني ما كنت متوقعه انه انه الموضوع
الحجاب مسؤوليه تمام وهذا قرار شخصي برجع
لك يعني احنا مش في صدد النقاش فيك خليني
اسالك النوم كل اللي تنمروا عليك هل اجوا
احد اكلمك بينك وبينه انه يعني يتكلم
يتكلم معك بهدوء وبدون هذا الصراخ وهذه
الشتيمه لانه الشتيمه منفره تبعدك عن
الشيء صحيح
[موسيقى]
وطلعوا فيديوهات يعني اي حدا صار اللي بده
يحكي يطلع بالفيديو ما ينصحني على الخاص
ولا بطريقه منيحه حتى لانه يعني هيك
السوشيال ميديا خليني احكي بانه اليوم انت
عمرك 18 سنه
العمر ان شاء الله الناس يقولون
عدد متابع نزل متابعيني
اصلا يعني انا هذا الاشي ما بفكر فيه انا
اللي بريحني يعني قراري انا البعض ممكن
يقول
يا سالي بانه انت طالما حطيتي حياتك
الشخصيه على الملا عن طريق حسابات على
السوشيال ميديا لازم تكوني محضره حالك
لانه الناس راح تتدخل والناس راح يكون في
الها راي في كل شيء انت بتعمليه كيف
بتتعاملي مع هاي الفكره كيف بتفكري بهذا
الموضوع هلا انا
من اول ما صارت التدخلات هاي بلشت ما افتح
السوشيال ميديا اول ما شلحه الحجاب ما
فتحت السوشيال ميديا ما كنت اشوف الكومنت
اي كومنت سلبي اي اشي ما كنت اشوفه
وبالنسبه للتدخلات هاي انا كتير بتضايقني
يعني كتير بتضايق انه لانه انا بني ادمه
طبيعيه زيي زي اي حدا بس
هذه الكلمات التنمر كيف غيرت سالي من قبل
وضعت قبل السوشيال ميديا كنت حدا مختلف
تماما
لا ما بخاف لا هلا بطلت تخاف شو بتنصح هي
الفتيات او اي حدا حابب انه يكون في له
وجود قوي على السوشيال ميديا بس نفس الوقت
بحب خصوصيه قراراته الشخصيه شو بتقولي لهم
انت او انت اذا تكوني على السوشيال ميديا
ما في اشي اسمه ما حدش يدخل فيكي مستحيل
الكل يدخل فيك حتى لو حتى لو ما بدك يعني
فلازم تكوني قويه ولازم تكوني قويه اذا
بدك تفوتي هاد المجال
ممتاز شكرا جزيلا لك صانعه المحتوى سالي
العوضي مشاهدينا الاردنيه
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات